le bois qui brûle dans les fours en
pierre rehausse le goût des bégaud les
braises du charbon utilisé dans les
rôtisseries portugaise donne une saveur
unique au poulet des méthodes de cuisson
qui font partie la renommée culinaire
montréalaise
mais la fumée qui se dégage de ces
restaurants projette aussi dans
l'atmosphère des particules fines et
détériore la qualité de l'air dans le
voisinage il ya une concentration de
commerces une concentration
concentration de personnes
et puis on sait que l'exposition va être
un peu plus élevé que
dans les quartiers où ce qui après de
commerce ou la cuisson au bois est loin
d'être un grand polluants mais comme les
restaurants sont concentrés dans des
quartiers densément peuplés la fumée
peut entraîner des ennuis de santé
une journée de mauvaise qualité de l'air
les gens qui ont des problèmes de coeur
prennent cardiaque ou des problèmes au
niveau des poumons peuvent avoir des
agrégations alors des crises cardiaques
chez des personnes qui avaient déjà un
problème cardiaque
la santé publique recommande donc à la
ville d'agir surtout qu'il existe des
solutions pour limiter la pollution liée
à la cuisson au bois par exemple saint
viateur mégots utilisent des for hybrid
90 % de la chaleur vient du gaz naturel
le 10 % de voix donne le goût de fumé au
bégaud à la rôtisserie ma poule mouillée
dans le plateau mont royal
le patron a investi dans une toute
nouvelle oat
il va bientôt installer un système pour
épurer la fumée qui lui a coûté 50 mille
dollars pour illuminer toute les acteurs
tout la boucane de tout temps complet il
m'a garanti que c'est après 130 x
efficace
le restaurateur est donc prêt à investir
mais il tient à la cuisson ou charbon de
bois nous plaire sur l'île charron de
voici le dossier des farc en 3 greer sur
le gazon électrique
c'est tellement différent la ville de
montréal reconnaît l'importance de ce
type de restauration pour la métropole
mais soutient qu'il faut aussi améliorer
la qualité de l'air
la ville prépare donc un projet de
règlement dont l'objectif serait de
réduire de 85 % les émissions de
particules fines liées à la cuisson au
bois
les détails de ce règlement devrait être
connue d'ici la fin de l'été ici vincent
maisonneuve radio canada montréal